anklage wegen auftragsmord der
generalbundesanwalt macht russland
verantwortlich die bundesregierung droht
moskau mit konsequenzen wirtschaftskrimi
beim münchner dax-konzern
zahlungsabwickler wirecard stürzt an der
börse abgesucht werden zwei milliarden
euro und abrechnung mit donald trump der
frühere sicherheitsberater john bolton
macht den us präsidenten in einem
enthüllungsbuch schwere vorwürfe
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg dritten abend und
willkommen zum nachrichtenüberblick an
diesem donnerstag an meiner seite ist
norbert lehmann für den sport ein
stimmwunder von wir beginnen mit einem
mord der das deutsch russische
verhältnis massiv belastet denn die
bundesanwaltschaft geht davon aus dass
die russische regierung diesen mord in
auftrag gegeben hat es geschah vor zehn
monaten mitten in der hauptstadt ein 40
jahre alter georgier wird von einem
fahrrad aus mit schüssen in den kopf und
rücken getötet
als mutmaßlichen täter nimmt die polizei
einen russen fest heute hat die
bundesanwaltschaft anklage wegen mordes
erhoben andreas künast hat die details
das ist der anfang einer diplomatischen
krise deren ausgang unabsehbar ist
russlands botschafter am nachmittag im
auswärtigen amt nur die begrüßung ist
freundlich die regierung die botschafter
vertritt gilt seit heute offiziell als
auftraggeberin eines politischen mordes
auf deutschem boden und die
bundesregierung behält sich weitere
maßnahmen in diesem fall ausdrücklich
vor dieser fall ist das attentat auf
einen russischen staatsfeind auf
kommandant tonika moskaus gegner im
tschetschenien-krieg seit zehn jahren
auf der flucht er kommt bis berlin am
hellichten freitag 23 august erschießt
ihn im kleinen tiergarten mutmaßlich
dieser russe laut anklage im auftrag der
regierung in moskau
es kann nicht sein dass der kreml nach
ansicht des generalbundesanwalts aus
politischen motiven menschen bei uns
mafiös liquidieren lässt und wie immer
noch denken wir sind vor allem frauen
der russischen regierung als
blutrünstigen banditen bezeichnet putin
das mordopfer dementiert aber den
deutschen vorwurf merkels regierung
weist zwei russische diplomaten aus weil
moskau die rechtshilfeersuchen ignoriere
bis heute sei hilfe das falsche wort
russland hat auf die anfragen nicht so
aufgeklärt nicht so geantwortet dass es
diese sprache wert wären
mindestens einer weiß wie es wirklich
war
ihm wird nun in berlin der prozess
gemacht
wie sehr belastet dieser mode das
verhältnis zu russland wie geht die
bundesregierung darum nur der aus
minister spricht von einem
schwerwiegenden vorgang und droht
weitere sanktionen an aber abgesehen
davon scheint mir die linie der
bundesregierung noch im wesentlichen
geprägt zu sein von verärgerter
realpolitik erfahrene außenpolitiker
meinen das sei zwar jetzt die traurige
bestätigung des ja eh schon vermuteten
aber man müsse trotzdem mit russland im
gespräch bleiben für viele andere in
berlin auch aus den reihen der
regierungskoalition ist diese
diplomatische reaktion aber nicht mehr
ausreichend man könne nicht hinnehmen
dass ein anderer staat hier gezielte
tötungen vornimmt und es wird dabei auch
auf die briten verwiesen die hätten nach
dem nervengift anschlag auf den
doppelagenten skripal und das war nur in
anführungsstrichen ein mordversuch
massiv zurück geschlagen damals hatten
28 staaten über 140 russische diplomaten
ausgewiesen davon ist berlin aber weit
entfernt
die einschätzung unseres
hauptstadtkorrespondenten vielen dank
theo koll am ersten juli übernimmt
deutschland für ein halbes jahr die
eu-ratspräsidentschaft für die
bundeskanzlerin wird es wohl die letzte
große mission ihrer 16 jährigen amtszeit
unterstellte sie ihre pläne im bundestag
vor und betonte noch nie waren
zusammenhalt und solidarität in europa
so wichtig patricia wiedemeier berichtet
noch hat die koalition gesprächsbedarf
bei den themen asyl und kurzarbeit noch
gibt es keinen konkreten fahrplan für
die deutsche eu ratspräsidentschaft
daher viel allgemein ist heute die
bewältigung der korona pandemie sie
bleibe die größte herausforderung in der
geschichte der eu europa im vergleich zu
anderen regionen der welt diese krisen
bewältigt
das wird über den wohlstand der
europäischen bürgerinnen und bürger
entscheiden und über europas rolle in
der welt
in diesem geist aber ich mitte mai
gemeinsam mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten ihm einen waggon 1 500
milliarden starken form für die
wirtschaftliche erholung europas
vorgeschlagen
zu viele neue schulden die zudem nicht
an strukturreformen in den ländern
gebunden sein so die kritik der
opposition unserem land droht eine nie
dagewesene welle von arbeitslosigkeit
unternehmenspleiten der mittelstand
verarmt und in dieser situation haben
wir auch keine milliarden zu verschenken
denn wir müssen uns selbst helfen mich
wundert dass über 500 milliarden
gesprochen wird ohne dass man vorher
weiß wofür
zuerst ist doch die frage was brauchen
wir und danach was kostet es denn sonst
wird aus einer bazooka mit wunsch nur
eine gießkanne corona sicherlich das
hauptthema der nächsten sechs monate
doch es gibt weitere wie
flüchtlingspolitik und klimaschutz zu
vergleichsweise gut wie wir in
deutschland durch die korona krise
gekommen sind wären wir doch
prädestiniert dafür beim klimaschutz
jetzt wirklich eine führende rolle zu
übernehmen
frau bundeskanzlerin sie haben jetzt die
chance die richtigen weichen zu stellen
nutzen sie um die eu zu einer
gemeinschaft zu machen in der nicht
soziale spaltung aufrüstung und
abschottung ganz oben stehen viele
probleme viele themen für die deutsche
eu präsidentschaft mehr informationen
zum deutschen eu ratsvorsitz finden sie
online in der zdf- heute- app dort gibt
es antworten auf viele fragen sowie die
gesamte rede der bundeskanzlerin zum
nachschauen zur corona krise die
infektionen in deutschland nehmen wieder
zu
dabei sind zwei große lokale ausbrüche
bislang nur teilweise in der statistik
erfasst darüber berichten wir gleich
zunächst die bundesweiten zahlen im
durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben tage
steckten sich 300 menschen täglich neu
mit dem koma virus an
eine aktuelle massen infektion ist im
schlachtbetrieb der firma tönnies im
heißt gütersloh dort bleiben jetzt
schulen und kitas bis zu den
sommerferien geschlossen und auch im
nahegelegenen bielefeld wurden kinder
von turniers beschäftigten nach hause
geschickt nach wie vor ist offen wie
genau es zu den inzwischen 730
bestätigten infektionen kam 5300 tests
stehen noch aus thomas münten berichtet
nur noch restarbeiten laufenden turniers
stammwerk in rheda wiedenbrück
geschlachtet wird nicht mehr
doch in der stadt nähert sich der unmut
schulen und kitas hinzu die eltern
aufgebracht wir keine
betreuungsmöglichkeiten haben für unsere
kinder und somit auch einen
arbeitsausfall ansteht
jedes mal wenn eine neue welle kommt
machen wir wieder alles zu ist das der
weg das kann es nicht sein
die 7000 tennis mitarbeiter sind
unterdessen eigentlichen quarantäne aber
offenbar ohne jede kontrolle
einkaufserlebnisse von heute morgen
wir gehen weiterhin zum aldi und zum
netto und zum kaufland und kaufen dort
ein und dort gibt es mit der
einheimischen bevölkerung sage ich mal
eine hohe schnittmenge auch wir gehen
dahin und das machen wie dieses gefühl
wie es zu der massiven infektion im
schlachthaus kommen konnte ist noch
absolut unklar
eine ansteckung bei wochenend besuchen
zu hause schließt die biologin isabella
eckerle eigentlich aus die
inkubationszeit ist etwa zwischen fünf
von sechs tagen
das praktisch viele hundert personen
sich gleichzeitig just an diesem
wochenende in der familie angesteckt
haben also das halt ich sowohl auf die
wahrscheinlichkeit so eines ereignisses
alter hinblick auf die inkubationszeit
eher unwahrscheinlich dass hygiene
maßnahmen bei tönnies versagt haben
vermutet die gewerkschaft
wir erwarten dass jetzt endlich endlich
scharfe massnahmen ergriffen werden
jetzt ist auch die zeit des redens
vorbei es muss gehandelt werden auch bei
annecy das unternehmen wollte sich heute
nicht weiter zu dem corona ausbruch
äußern
auch in göttingen in niedersachsen gibt
es wieder einen großen infektionsherd
etwa 100 corona fälle in einem hochhaus
das komplette gebäude wurde vorerst
unter quarantäne gestellt etwa 700
personen sind davon betroffen
da viele der
bewohner kontakt untereinander hätten
habe man sich zu der maßnahme
entschieden so ein sprecher der stadt
inzwischen seien alle getestet worden
und 60 ergebnisse stünden noch aus trotz
solcher hotspots in den meisten kreisen
bleiben die korona zahlen überschaubar
und deshalb soll nach den sommerferien
die schulen den normalen betrieb wieder
aufnehmen mit allen schülern so haben es
die kultusminister der länder heute
beschlossen das heißt aber auch
abstandsregeln können dann nicht mehr
eingehalten werden
anna bruder berichtet regelbetrieb ja
aber unter auflagen dazu gehören feste
lerngruppen und hygienemaßnahmen wie
regelmäßiges lüften und es gibt einen
gemeinsamen beschluss der kultusminister
der auch die abstandsregel kippt wir
sind der auffassung dass zur
gewährleistung des rechts auf bildung
von kindern und jugendlichen nach den
sommerferien wieder ein regulärer
schulbetrieb nach geltender schulstunden
tafel in den schulen vor ort im
klassenverband stattfinden muss und das
bedeutet das ist klar die konsequenz
dass die ein meter fünfzig
abstandsregelung entfallen muss sofern
es das infektionsgeschehen zulässt
schüler und lehrer warten schon lange
darauf wie es nach den sommerferien
weiter gehen kann und wünschen sich
klarheit
meine schüler sind sehr verunsichert
durch die bank also von der fünften bis
zur bis zu den eltern die ich jetzt hat
und sie wünschen sich klarheit in den in
den richtlinien die wünschen sich dass
sie hoffentlich vor den ferien schon
wissen wie es nach den ferien weitergeht
elternvertreter begrüßten grundsätzlich
die rückkehr zum normalen schulbetrieb
aber man müsse auf erneute corona
bedingte schulschließungen vorbereitet
sein
gerade was die digitalisierung und den
den fernunterricht angeht den
qualifizierten fernunterricht angeht
dass wir hier klare vorgaben haben wie
das ablaufen soll dennis muss auf jeden
fall eine feedback funktion mit dabei
sein dass die kinder auch eine
rückmeldung kriegen wir haben über das
thema digitalisierung des lehrens und
lernens natürlich lange diskutiert wir
werden das weiter vorantreiben wir
werden die erfahrung die wir jetzt
gemacht haben in der korona krise auf
dem werden wir aufbauen
die zeit drängt denn in manchen
bundesländern stehen die sommerferien
schon vor der tür
wer knapp zwei milliarden euro einfach
nicht wiederfinden kann hat ein problem
etwas in dieser art ist offenbar einem
dax-konzern passiert der schon länger im
gerede ist dem zahlungsdienstleister
wirecard
der konzern hatte in seinen büchern die
milliardensumme stehen externe
wirtschaftsprüfer konnten das geld bei
den angegebenen bank mit in asien aber
nicht aufspüren
die folge panikverkäufe an der börse
alexander pohl über wirecard und sein
geschäftsmodell fast jedem ist wirecard
schon mal begegnet hinter vielen
bargeldlosen zahlungen steckt der
dienstleister aus aschheim bei münchen
der garantiert den händlern dass sie am
ende auch ihr geld bekommen
dafür legt wirecard hohe summen zurück
um im zweifelsfall wie eine versicherung
einzuspringen von rund zwei milliarden
dieser rücklagen fehlt nun jede spur
wirecard sieht sich als betrugsopfer und
erklärt es bestehen hinweise dass dem
abschlussprüfer von einem treuhänder
unrichtige seiten bestätigungen zu
täuschung zwecken vorgelegt wurden es
geht also möglicherweise um gefälschte
kontoauszüge doch nicht zum ersten mal
werfen die bilanzen von wirecard fragen
auf der financial times zufolge sollen
mitarbeiter des asiengeschäfts zwischen
2016 und 2018 scheingeschäfte getätigt
bilanzen gefälscht und gelder veruntreut
haben
dies zeigten interne untersuchungen
wirecard chef brown bestreitet jegliches
fehlverhalten während einer erneuten
prüfung soll wirecard versucht haben die
börse mit positivmeldungen zu beruhigen
seit anfang juni ermittelt die
staatsanwaltschaft wegen des verdachts
auf marktmanipulation die geschäftsräume
von wirecard wurden durchsucht sowohl
die bundesanstalt für
finanzdienstleistungsaufsicht als auch
die münchner staatsanwaltschaft haben
angekündigt ihre untersuchungen im fall
wirecard auszuweiten
sie nahm eine seiner börse in frankfurt
wirecard das war eine der
erfolgreichsten gründer stories
hierzulande
was bedeutet es für den
wirtschaftsstandort deutschland wenn so
ein hoffnungsträger so strauchelt nichts
gutes denn deutschland hat nicht viele
unternehmen in diesem bereich high-tech
gerade in corona zeiten und mit
neben der digitalisierung ist wirecard
in einer sparte tätig die immer
wichtiger wird in dax und damit an der
börse vertreten sind in dieser liga
gerade einmal sap und eben wirecard
letzteres verspielt gerade ruf und
unternehmenswert scharenweise haben
anleger wirecard heute den rücken
gekehrt die aktie des
finanzdienstleisters ist um 62 prozent
abgestürzt und damit wurden innerhalb
von nur einem tag 7,6 milliarden euro
börsenwert vernichtet das ist der größte
tagesverlust den ein dax-wert jemals
verkraften musste schon fragen sich
einige ob wirecard nun die erste
börsenliga bald verlassen muss das
vertrauen in das unternehmen ist schwer
erschüttert und große handelsketten
darunter aldi zählt wirecard zb zu
seinen kunden
wie eben bekannt wurde rolle nun im
vorstand bereits die ersten köpfe dann
kann auch frankfurts enorm eine in die
usa
dort sorgt ein neues enthüllungsbuch
über donald trump für reichlich wirbel
geschrieben hat es john boten der
früheren nationale sicherheitsberater
des präsidenten
noch ist das werk nicht auf dem markt
aber erste auszüge
danach sollte china um hilfe für seine
wiederwahl gebeten haben
außerdem sei der präsident schockierend
uninformiert tram kontakten sei ein
lügner eines tabs im streit sind sie
geschieden nun packt er aus john bolton
ehemaliger sicherheitsberater von
präsident rob in seinem buch the room
where it happened beschreibt er trotz
amtsführung als komplett eigennützig
jede entscheidung fälle der mit seiner
wiederwahl im kopf so sollten den
chinesischen präsidenten gebeten haben
mit dem aufkauf von mehr us
agrarprodukten seine wiederwahlchancen
zu erhöhen
trump so boten sie inständig
sicherzustellen dass er gewinnt mehrfach
so bolton hätte trump strafrechtliche
ermittlungen gegen die machthaber in
china und in der türkei unterbunden
internierung der muslimischen uiguren in
china hätte er gut geheißen laut bolten
hätte trump gesagt dass sie mit dem bau
der lager fortfahren sollte es sei genau
die richtige sache die zu tun sei das
weiße haus will die veröffentlichung des
buches mit einer klage verhindern was
drin stünde sei falsch und geheim so
trump in einer ersten reaktion boten
bricht das gesetz er war ein ruinierter
kerl der senat wollte ihn nicht
durchwinken so gab ich ihm eine position
wo ich ihn hinsetzen konnte von seiner
arbeit aber war ich nicht begeistert
dieses buch ist gewichtig denn es stammt
nicht von einem anonymen schreiber aus
dem weißen haus sondern von einem der
engsten berater trumps washington
allerdings schüttelt den kopf darüber
dass wollten sich geweigert hat im
amtsenthebungsverfahren gegen kamp aus
zu sagen da hätte er tatsächlich etwas
bewirken können
nun bleibt es den wählern überlassen
über präsident trump zu entscheiden im
november an der wahlurne einen traurigen
neuen rekord meldet das
flüchtlingshilfswerk der vereinten
nationen
noch nie zuvor waren so viele menschen
in ihren heimatländern auf der flucht
2009 10 fast 80 millionen
die zahl hat sich seit 2010 nahezu
verdoppelt eine verbesserung sei nicht
absehbar
mehr als zwei drittel der flüchtlinge
stammen laut statistik aus den fünf
ländern syrien venezuela afghanistan dem
südsudan und nimmer der
bundesgerichtshof hat das urteil gegen
einen der beiden berliner autoraser
bestätigt dass gegen dem zweiten fahrer
wurde dagegen aufgehoben
die beiden jungen männer waren 2016 bei
einem illegalen autorennen mit tempo 170
über den kudamm gerast einer rammte das
auto eines rentners der noch an der
unfallstelle starb
mord aus niedrigen beweggründen so der
bgh über die tat des unfallfahrers bei
dem anderen fahrer sei eine
mittäterschaft allerdings nicht belegt
und damit sind wir bei dir norbert und
beim fußball und einer top personalie
aus der bundesliga nationalspieler timo
werner
verlässt leipzig und wechselt zum fc
chelsea die ablösesumme 53 millionen
euro
der 24-jährige wird schon im juli in
london antreten und steht deshalb rb für
die noch laufende champions league nicht
mehr zur verfügung
letztendlich ist es eine sache die die
wir dann auch so akzeptieren müssen und
respektieren müssen
und jetzt wird alles geben jetzt in den
nächsten beiden spielen dass wir unser
ziel champions league erreichen hat ja
gestern auch wieder ein tor gemacht und
auch in england rollt der ball wieder
riester der premier league gestern unter
anderem mit dem duell manchester city
gegen den fc arsenal das team von city
coach pep guardiola gewann 13 0 zeichen
gegen rassismus beim ersten premier
league spiel seit fast 100 tagen bei den
gästen gibt es früh verletzungen david
lewis kommt für us-öl auf dem platz das
hat folgen nachspielzeit erster hälfte
der brasilianer verschätzt sich bahn
frei für achim sterling zum 1 0 für
manchester
gleich nach dem wechsel luiz foult den
algerier maries rote karte und elfmeter
für manchester kevin de bruyne mit dem 2
0 in unterzahl kommt es zu keinem
treffer mehr sieht die schon viel zogen
erzielt in der nachspielzeit das 3 0 der
endstand
guardiolas manchester verkürzt den
abstand auf tabellenführer liverpool der
am sonntag noch nicht meister werden
kann
[Applaus]
schwere aufgaben für die deutschen
handballerinnen bei der em im dezember
heute die auslosung deutschland trifft
in der gruppe d nicht nur auf das
spitzenteam von mit gastgeber norwegen
sondern neben polen auch noch auf starke
rumänien und zum finalturnier der
basketball bundesliga in münchen
wer hat im viertelfinal hinspiel der
ko-runde alba berlin die bg göttingen
klar geschlagen
der überragende jonas matissek mit einem
wahren kunst nur von der mittellinie zur
klaren pausenführung 52 10 29 uhr die
berliner die ihrer favoritenrolle
absolut gerecht wurden mit 93 zu 68
gewinnt alba der forschung also ziemlich
beruhigend für das rückspiel am samstag
das dankeschön
das wetter bringt jetzt auch im norden
kräftigen regen ansonsten wird's ganz
freundlich details hat gleich katja
honnefer marietta slomka begrüßt sie um
viertel vor zehn im heute journal
danke für ihr interesse haben sie noch
einen schönen abend und bis morgen wenn
sie mögen
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
den abend meine damen und herren da
liegt das regenband schräg über
deutschland und zog heute ganz
allmählich weiter nach norden
es brachte regenschauer und gewitter mit
und es wird uns auch noch in der nacht
und morgen beschäftigen
da regnet es nämlich recht kräftig
zwischen weser und elbe sind auch
einzelne gewitter dabei auch aus den
alpen heraus gibt es einige regenschauer
sonst lockern die wolken auf und in der
feuchten luft kann sich auch mal nebel
bilden unter den regen und
gewitterwolken bleibt die nacht bild mit
werten zwischen 16 und 14 grad sonst
sinken die werte auf 13 bis 9 grad und
morgen liegen die höchsttemperaturen
deutschlandweit recht einheitlich um die
20 grad kühler bleibt es am alpenrand
mit 17 grad am wärmsten wird es am
niederrhein mit 24 grad und morgen
regnet es in norddeutschland heftig
weiter innerhalb von 24 stunden können
durchaus 50 liter regen pro quadratmeter
fallen
hier in diesem streifen von sylt bis
nach berlin sind auch einige gewitter
dabei
deutlich freundlicher sieht aus richtung
ruhrgebiet auch über der rhön oder im
oberpfälzer wald scheint häufig die
sonne
besonders am nachmittag kann es aber
dann doch hier im süden einige
regenschauer und gewitter geben
sie begleiten uns auch noch am samstag
danach wird es von tag zu tag sonniger
und werner schön am 9